Salam alaikum I'm here visiting my Nana
my grandmother and I want to you know
the last the final master sent the man
kind of pro Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him who's a brother of Jesus
Moses Abraham they all and you hear me
all the time making that connection so
people could understand that they all
were brothers of one another they
brought the same way of life that call
to connect your heart to the one who
created the heart the created the
heavens and earth and dawa is an
obligation and I have my grandmother
here for those people who think I'm too
old what do I know the Prophet SAW some
had said convey for me even if it be one
ayah and she's sharing with me a story
of she has a Catholic friend Yuba and
how they are really good friends
and she's always sharing with her the
message and this is something that you
can take home with you and you can get
motivated to go ahead and share because
if you care you share so I'll make home
well a couple say Allah tell us Nana a
little bit about Luba your friend and
some of the conversation you have with
her so no time how I comment to America
all the times he called visitor said
that it out I move the only time called
me and she started to cry she missed me
so much
and we talked to about Allah all the
time I said alas the only one she
believed it only one no more he have not
sown no no no he never died he never he
never born he never died he never had a
son then she believed it everything was
him that he he he creates everything
nobody can create like God created you
know go ahead and say say that for in
Bosnian and I'll also translate for the
people
and brocco Bataclan Bosnians further for
the Bosnians out there
Serbians Croatians whoever ya mean Amy
pre-travel he plucked a mr. Taymor say
ona miss amina yes'm no no we're drivin
a source of wattage la Dolas salami at a
movie a Kiwi akima see and I see taco
very pasta lasagna liquor are horrible
in cars a senior cheetah cool on OBS new
Yayoi OBS new used to follow you Sephora
Yousif al quran allah iike you suffer
obvious new anomaly between UV exposed
oprah uv8 prison edema die ba ba din'
EDI evey area Toriko
tom Nissim natok augustana would a lotta
quota who VX was a codeine automobile
asan rise david godina Dolas run a movie
a creator ii omaha kalashnikov all IJ
the Who Dat Donna
Charlie you now hazy scene country
nobody BOJ doe
so I gotta reckon aqua be lost I am on
recall that supposed to be T rat rat TV
oh yeah because II the Pope hidden named
escena nietzsche rodeo knee jamesina
knit is a rodeo knit each area t it own
Akari the various beautiful so that's a
aya from the Koran cool who Allahu Ahad
Allah who summit
lemme a lead well anula dwell a
McCulloch hookah when I had and she's
explaining to her in Bosnian doing her
best to explain a story of how she was
giving her sister and humanity how they
would talk together cry together and she
was shared the most important thing that
she has this Deen this way in life does
way of life from the crater telling her
sharing referred that the crater is one
and alone worthy of worship he has no
children he's not the father of anyone
he's truly self-sufficient and there is
nothing equal to God sharing the purpose
of life and you could do it too my
grandma is doing it why can't you go
ahead and share the message and at the
end they're still friends
the lady she accepted she believes the
in our heart and that's something that
resonates with human beings is pure
message of monotheism of worshipping the
crater not the creation and it's up to
God Almighty if he's gonna guide but
it's on us to go ahead and share you
share everything else why not share the
Deen and this is the tradition this is
the way of all the prophets that the
Creator sent sharing the purpose of life
why we've been created the good news a
paradise for those who believe act upon
righteousness and warn the people about
the Hellfire following your lust and
your desires turning away from the from
giving thanks to the one who created you
this was me taking a break with you and
you want to say Salaam telling bye-bye
Nana Salam alaikum peace be with you
sound like this middle of life Nana for
he was who along a hundred a long summer
day let merely do it immunity what a
miracle level 100 so cool who Allah say
he I lost one God is one the maker
America exactly a lot was somewhat lost
self-sufficient he doesn't need food or
drink he doesn't need to rest on the
seventh day okay I really had a problem
with that even before I do anything
about Islam God resting sounds like a
weak guy yeah Lamia lid well I'm you let
he begets not he doesn't have any
children nor was he a child or born of
anything or anyone
well I'm yeah cool a hug before I die
and there is nothing co-equal or
comparable to him at all nobody nothing
Jesus no nobody nobody is comparable to
the Creator nothing yeah
and that right there was in his essence
what I believe
you